all right they asked Toto Beckham jr.
after the game about the cleats that
they had to remove he and Jarvis Landry
had non-conforming cleats during the
first half and CBS reported during the
game against the Broncos that they
weren't going to be allowed to play in
the second half they didn't change their
cleats right and Odell Beckham jr. he
thinks that he is the only guy who's
ever been fined for not conforming with
the uniform rules who's ever been given
a hard time about not conforming and
that is so wrong and I'm not surprised
he thinks he's the only guy who's ever
been punished because he thinks he's the
only guy right yeah the world revolves
around Odell Beckham jr. I know that you
are enou doe Beckham I am banned but I'm
sorry at a certain point yeah you have
to say this isn't an issue of immaturity
this isn't an issue of naivete this is a
guy who thinks the Sun rises in his face
and sets up his ass and I'm sick of it
well he's a superstar okay he is and we
know wide receivers her a little bit
like that there's worse than the NFL
than Odell Beckham jr. this is where is
this is where it's weird to me okay this
is the only thing where it's weird and
again I'm not for that like I don't want
them wearing the $200,000 watch in the
field and giving people the ammo there I
lost an earring and the Scout scrum with
Marlon Humphrey like yeah that's your
fault you decide to wear you know lots
of carrots in your ear and it's football
and things like that happen but where I
think this is just weird
okay I've never heard of you're not
allowed to play unless you've changed
the cleats never we find certain fun I'm
just telling you I've been around the
NFL my whole life I've never seen a
player pulled off the field because your
visor isn't right and they're not gonna
let you play that to me is a little bit
of a guy who's a superstar who's under
the microscope and like somebody from
345 par caps taking special notice of
him all these guys just get fined like
you mentioned Kamara they get fine
that's all there is
oh okay I don't have the right cleats on
any Kent team I was ever a part of
that's where it so that's where I just
want to push back a little
whoa oh that's weird there's yourself
gonna play there is a procedure I'm
aware of though that if they find you
enough times it will eventually say
that's it now I don't know if they slip
these cleats on during
the first half it sounds like Odell
Beckham jr. just decided to wear the
white cleats that had some decoration on
right the rule is very simple yeah it
used to be and they should go back to it
so there'd be no misunderstanding
everybody just wore the same shoes it's
a uniform the whole idea is you don't
want to individualize a uniform because
these guys are supposed to look like
they are on a team and they're all
wearing the same thing and it drives me
crazy I still can't get used to it when
because when you see guys wearing
different shoes it just it messes with
your eyes sure you want to see some the
bottom yeah what's the big deal it's
just freaking shoes people its shoes
during a football game but not the
athletes that's not the way they are
sometimes you just got to get it's just
the way a fleeter that way you know me
how you see me I like my sneakers and
doing all that too but yeah we had but
if we but here's a fat guy we wear dress
shoes yes right right you don't come out
in your Jordans no all right you perform
yes you're right I can form and I get
that and also I think we have to explain
this little other Avenue of the
conversation to the Browns changed what
they were gonna wear uniform Wow doesn't
matter and that doesn't matter he still
can choose black white or a secondary
color it doesn't matter they went from
white jerseys taupe to brown jerseys
well that's a that's that's a false
argument it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter at all doesn't matter that he
could still wear black white or a
secondary team count okay so you're
saying if he had the white I just want
to make sure I got this right so please
tell me if I'm wrong if they were
wearing the white uniforms the shoes he
wore still wouldn't have not have been
allowed yet would he could white he was
gonna wear white cleats right they
switched to brown jerseys yeah so he
wasn't gonna wear white cleats and this
is more about I think how he thinks the
shoes look yeah well definitely right so
so he had white cleats with this like
joker stuff on him and he decided he was
gonna wear them so he came out with
black cleats in the second half I just
look in my mind there's nothing that's
more functional than the equipment you
have on your feet when you're a football
player yeah and I understand that it's a
way to make a statement it's a way to
separate yourself it's a way to build
your brand and all that stuff there's a
point where it's just look these are
your shoes that you wear these are your
tools right you don't see guys paint and
decorations on their hammer
you just get your hammer and you go
pound your nails that these shoes are
hammers these shoes are because he was
complaining about when he switched to
black cleats in the second half they
hurt his feet
well you know what if you would have had
a conforming pair of cleats from the
get-go you would have had a comfortable
pair yeah I just I just think I think
it's also more to it than that
look liars live by the credo of look
good play good okay there's a lot of
guys that are messing with all that
stuff also there's millions of dollars
at stake with what he has at Nike there
too oh there's more than here than just
a guy that has a hammer that he doesn't
want to dress up and here's the other
side of it too
your team sucks yeah so that should not
be an issue the last thing we should be
talking about with the two and six
Browns is what shoes Odell Beckham jr. I
hear you I get you know I always think I
really challenged in this and I would
really like to know the answer to this
and maybe you could dig through this
through you know whoever you know in the
NFL whatever I just don't know anybody
who's been told you're not playing
unless you change your cleats I don't
never heard of that
that's a fair point that's a fair point
unless the Monday night because in join
for non-conforming CLE right in past
weeks and they finally decided we're not
gonna let you play but you know what
here's the thing right if that's the
case they wouldn't let them on the field
at all that's not we're gonna we're
gonna sort I mean yeah then same with
the visor and week two against the Jets
I'm just again and I might be wrong and
if I am please we'll discuss it tomorrow
and we'll figure this out I have just
never seen a guy taking off oh you're
inside the 10-yard line get off the
field
we've now deemed your visor has to come
off at this second I've never heard of
that in the history of the NFL so and
maybe I'm wrong I'm not I don't know I'm
not saying I'm right about this not
something I study here I'm just but I've
never heard of it here's the thing that
okay and and this is part of the
challenge in life of dealing with
whatever circumstances come your way and
coloring within those lines yeah because
right or wrong if Odell Beckham jr. has
become this personality that there's
somebody at 345 Park Avenue who's who's
out to get him in some way and is trying
to mess with them by saying what he can
and can't wear there's a point you just
have to accept it and you have to
operate within those confines so it
doesn't become a distraction for your
team it's wrong it's not fair I don't
like it but they've put this barrier
here and they're on a damn thing I can
do about
so I may as well confirm to it so I'll
have to get new cleats at halftime so I
don't have to leave the game and take
off my visor because I know that they're
being jerks and it's directed at me if
that's how he feels hey you know what I
think he's wrong when he says he's being
singled out but if he is being singled
out then do what you have to do to not
be singled out I think there's a point
where you just have to give well yeah I
mean you're right I mean hey listen you
know 3:45 if they are watching over them
they're watching over him because he's a
superstar and he does he's got that kind
of like you know power to where when I
watch The Cleveland Browns
not gonna lie I always looked down to
see what cleats Odell Beckham jr. is
gonna wear I'm kind of a you know shoot
for lack of a better phrase that way I
like that kind there are probably better
terms than that probably but it could
have been better was but that one I
think was pretty appropriate and fit the
right way I like you know I like to
check that stuff out but either way your
point is real and I get it I just would
like to know the answers to those
threats got one touchdown through eight
games this year thirty nine catches 575
yards that puts him on pace for 78
receptions 1,150 yards he had 77 and 10
52 last year in 12 games with the Giants
he's only had one 16-game season for his
career at 1367 receiving yards that year
that was 2016 with the Giants so the guy
I don't know he's not producing
superstar stats though that to me should
be a far bigger concern for Odell
Beckham jr. than his shoes than his
visor than his watch and I just there's
a point where there's a I look a
Cassandra I look hundred there's just a
point where it's played out it's too
much and you got to focus on your game
not all this other crap yeah and we're
just giving everybody ammunition Baker
may be a talking point when the team you
play for stinks the talking point should
be what do I need to do to make the team
better
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports